des atteintes portées contre les
enseignants ces atteintes portées dans
l'espace scolaires sont
évidemment insupportables et le mot est
vous me l'accorderez doucement
ehémique insupportable parce qu'elle
viole le sanctuaire
républicain le havre de
connaissance notre berceau laïque de la
transmission t des valeurs
républicaines valeur évidemment pour
nous tous euh cardinal et au nom de la
liberté de l'égalité de la fraternité on
se doit bien sûr de préserver l'école de
toute forme de radicalisation
d'obscurantisme et de
violence l'école au fond est le le le le
premier espace de transmission des
valeurs
de notre République et elle mérite une
mobilisation
forte une mobilisation sans faille de la
part de tous les acteurs de l'État pour
que les enseignants puissent continuer à
former nos enfants à éveiller
leur leur esprit sans en courir de
risque et sans craindre pour leur vie ou
pour celle de leurs
proches tous les acteurs de l'État sont
unis pour protéger l'école républicaine
et mon ministère évidemment ne fait pas
exception à à cette règle impérieuse
bien au contraire euh on se doit d'abord
d'apporter à tous les niveaux de la
menace qui pèsent sur nos enseignants et
nos écoles une réponse
coordonnée immédiate ferme et et
dissuasive et d'abord il est essentiel
que tout acte
répréhensible euh ou porteur d'une
menace à l'encontre
je dis de cette façon de la sphère
scolaire soit portter la connaissance de
l'autorité judiciaire
ou à la connaissance de l'autorité
administrative pour qu'une réponse y
soit donnée